Rodney is in Atlanta Georgia hi Rodney
how are you hey honey
better than I deserve what's up quick
questions down I've been loosely
following your pretense for a while I
had the system but I'm ready to get like
more serious with it okay my question
was every year I get a bonus about 10 to
15 percent of my income and I make fifty
thousand right now good for you and I
get the bonus last year is about 38 back
taxes so this year with my income what
my bonus should I start my emergency
fund of $1,000 or should i tackle the
2700 having credit card debt you should
be able to do both oh I'm sorry and uh I
want to pay my off too I want to start
that okay well we're gonna go we teach
what we call the baby steps and they
tell you what to do first what the new
second what to do third baby step ones
what you do first and that save $1,000
as your starter begin our emergency fund
baby step two is you pay off all of your
debts except your home by listing them
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything but the little one attack
the little one and work it in that order
so in this case we're going to assume
the credit cards are more than the car
payment right card that no pick with my
car is a 93 thousand on it but it
Cortney kvb is only worth 66
9300 yes sorry yes man 300 K so you owe
nine thousand three hundred but you owe
two thousand seven hundred on credit
cards yes so if we list your debts
smallest to largest after you save your
first thousand dollars and baby step one
then the next thing you would do is you
would be at attack your smallest debt
which will be the credit cards right
okay and then once they're gone then we
attack the car as fast as we can and you
just squeeze every dollar out of your
budget that you can you work extra you
have a garage sale you do anything you
can't and we're gonna just really lean
in and knock our dad out as fast as
possible so how fast you think you can
pay off nine thousand dollars making
fifty thousand if you don't have any
credit card debt that's my second
question if I can get it if I can get
the second question in pick up a second
job at the belly this looks like a four
to six hundred a month person so yeah
I'm gonna use that and then whatever I
got for like tax return next year about
everything else you can squeeze out of
your budget yeah I can squeeze out
Gordon
I could squeeze out like extra what 100
150 okay all right
and so let's just do some math let's say
we got to 900 you owe 9,000 wouldn't it
be 10 months yep
I mean so there you go man you're gonna
be dead free by this time next year do
you encourage using like tax returns
sure I did
sure and if you continue to get a tax
refund you need to adjust your
withholding because you got too much
coming out of your check well I think
this year is because I moved I just
bought my first place back in February
so I think that's why I'll get a big one
this year well that means you have too
much coming out of your track okay if
you get a tax refund it's because you
paid too much in okay so shut I have a
tax lady who I work with
she went to have her look at your tax
stubs and see if you can adjust your
withholding and take more home which
will also help you get the car paid off
faster is it do it do that now you can
adjust it midstream as long as your
company doesn't mind you adjusting it
okay just have a look at it and because
here's the thing if you get a $3,000 tax
refund that means you have $250 too much
coming out of your check every month
oh wow you see what I'm saying yeah last
year my tax return with a little bit
more than that so I guess I have too
much so you're loaning money to the
government all year tight with no
interest and then they give it back to
you and April and act like they're Santa
Claus oh yeah they realize that yeah
it's just you you're just got too much
coming out of your check that's what I
mean by adjusting your withholding so
yeah you need to see your tax person and
get that done dude I'm proud of you
you're really getting on this
congratulations Rodney thanks for being
a listener this is the Dave Ramsey show
you